hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video ich bin hier nicht alleine sondern
zusammen mit luca kurzen bart und war
das video los geht es ist kein richtiges
video sondern einfach der versuch ein
video aufzunehmen
dr gescheitert ist wir machen jetzt
nicht irgendwie so fallen besonders
lustig drauf und ich hoffe mal fürs
unterhalten für euch wir machen heute
etwas trainieren auf den zehenspitzen
weil luca so groß ist wir machen heute
etwas was ich mir ganz allein überlegt
habe einmal klatschen mit kannst ja ohne
spaß leute ich hab jetzt versetzte mich
am arsch weil keine ahnung warum aber
irgendwie sind wir familie und kann
eigentlich kein videos aufnehmen wie man
es trotzdem nur für euch und unsere nur
für euch zeigt das hilft beim öffnen
herzlos wm ok wir euch unsere community
bank verfügte
wir machen heute ein youtuber speed kurs
besuchen uns ein paar youtuber teste
dies heraus dann werde erst die antwort
weiß es besser und wir gucken wer
gewinnt ohne david bestrafung weil wir
sind wir als erstes einladen - also wenn
ihr das allererste eine bloody kurs für
die jetzt frei schon gesehen ja wir
leben hier gleichzeitig sagen dann die
richtige antwort führt seinen viktor
dafür ist die antwort gesagt das war der
test auch leute und jetzt geht's los mit
der zweiten frage also wandert der
geburt keine ahnung ich sage ich wir
beide keine am nächste runde
aber wenn die beiden nicht wissen wie
kriegen doch nicht die antwort angezeigt
hat er haustiere
ich würde sagen vier meerschweinchen
nein es geht um die veto macht sich gut
nicht einschlafen können wir hier siehst
du die 25
da gebietet mit julian zusammen weil die
emmi ist dein kind wieder kommen aus der
schwarzwald ins mikro heißt in echt
jahre julian co julian khol falsch
vielmehr die boni träsch hat ein kölner
war
mary s bpm ist die erwin kindheit
schreibt nicht die heimkehr julia christ
julian haben die band juli geburtstag
aber nennen auf youtube haben die beiden
bei dem janko 3 millionen bekannt guck
dir das cover an für die frage
und 20 wir sind weder betrunken noch auf
irgendwelchen drogen gar nicht ich hab
ne klausur geschrieben und einfach
bisher noch nicht mitgemacht und bürger
stellen
los geht's und nein sondern läuft beim
sortieren
vorbei